If my calculations are correct, and, let's face it, they always are, she should portal jump right about…
Ha-ha!
- We have bridge the gap between time and space.
- How shall we celebrate?
- I think you know
Boom [Dramatic music]
- Wait is that a Right Twix?
- Wait is that a Left Twix?
*each Anna stares into the other Annas soul*
- Ugh. Oh.
- This is garbage!
- If you're not Right, you're wrong.
- Join us or you'll, get left behind.
- Clearly you have no decency left.
- Obvi.
- Do you believe in magic?
- I do.
Whoa! What's going on?
We have met our mortal multi-verse enemies.
Well, they're both equally amazing,
so why don't you guys just trade off and try?
[Overlapping voices]
[Overlapping fighting]
It's time to decide.   Which side are you?
#LeftTwix        OR       #RightTwix